there's the movie don't worry darling
and then
there's the movie that needs to be made
about all the drama that went down in
venice welcome to entertainment tonight
y'all hollywood couldn't write it no
they couldn't write this one there is so
much to unpack and we're gonna make it
easy for y'all now we expected some
awkwardness between olivia wilde and
florence pew yeah but what we didn't see
coming is what went down between chris
pine and harry styles
did harry really spit on his co-star
twitter spiraled all morning posting
memes calling it spit gate and analyzing
these 10 seconds of viral video over and
over chris seems to freeze mid clap
looks at his lap and laughs to himself
but chris's rep released a statement
midday shutting down the speculation
calling it a ridiculous story and quote
a complete fabrication and the result of
an odd online illusion that is clearly
deceiving and allows for foolish
speculation
the awkwardness got rolling before that
drama florence arrived to venice in all
purple after the press conference olivia
was asked point blank about the rumored
feud that may or may not have started on
set because florence was upset about
olivia's romance with harry can you just
clear the air and address if there's
been a falling out there florence is a
force and we are so grateful that she's
able to make it tonight despite being in
production on dune as for all the
endless tabloid gossip and all the noise
out there i mean the internet feeds
itself i don't feel the need to
contribute i think it's sufficiently
well nourished
but let's just break down some of this
tension chris arrived to the red carpet
first then olivia then harry and finally
florence chris is carefully positioned
between olivia and florence the 26 year
old avoided any interaction with both
harry and olivia the two ladies sorta
kinda maybe celebrated each other later
the film received a seven minute
standing ovation and they appeared to
briefly lock gazes and smile
oh and there's more florence's stylist
posted this pic and captioned it simply
miss flow a not so subtle dig referring
to this leaked video hashtag time's up
olivia i think this might be a bit of a
wake-up call for miss flo
as if that wasn't enough chris pine
brought home two more meme worthy
moments check him out putting on his
sunglasses as the screening begins one
fan commenting oh that man is taking a
nap
and there's this chris appears to
completely zone out as harry talks to an
interviewer about don't worry darling
out september 23rd my favorite thing
about the movie is like it feels like a
like a movie
despite that drama there was one
touching moment in venice actor brendan
frazier got all choked up sobbing as he
received a six-minute standing ovation
for his role in the whale
[Music]
you